let's start though there was a clip that
went viral earlier in the week former
president barack obama
was being interviewed and basically made
light of critical race theory which as
we're
live streaming this right now is the
number one trend on twitter
but he's not having much of it let's
take a look i also think that there are
certain right-wing media venues for
example
that monetize and capitalize on stoking
the fear and resentment
of uh a white population that is
witnessing a changing america and seeing
uh demographic changes and
and do everything they can to give
people a sense that
um their way of life is threatened and
that people are trying to take advantage
of them and we're seeing it
right now right where uh you would think
with all the public policy debates that
are taking place right now
that you know the republican party would
uh be
engaged in a significant debate about
how are we going to deal with the
economy and what are we going to do
about climate change and what are we
going to do about
lo and behold the single most
important issue to them apparently right
now is critical race theory
who knew that that was the threat to our
republic
so it's quite an extraordinary clip
actually because
he's making light of really the set of
ideas that is just running rampant
through the country right now and
destroying all of our institutions uh
harris i have according to my paperwork
here you are black is that correct
well yeah i'm definitely a member of the
black community but actually like obama
we we have white mothers my mother is of
irish descent
so while i've never been accused of
being a white person obviously i'm a
part of the black community
the one thing that uh that stands out to
me with obama is the fact that hey
he's trying to downplay the attack
that's going towards our children
critical race theory at its very core
is is absolutely racist it's it's
teaching and wants to teach our kids
to look at other kids around them and
people adults
and judge them based on the color of
their skin
it's evil it's abhorrent and it
absolutely is a threat to the foundation
of this country because our [ __ ] our
kill
our kids our children are the next
generation they are the bedrock of this
country
so let me get you so freaking downplay
like that's disgusting so you're telling
me that we shouldn't be judging based on
the color of skin and we shouldn't think
think we shouldn't think that things
like being on time
and working hard that those are white
things you mean you're saying that
you mean everyone can do those things
it's quite extraordinary stu
you've been a conservative for a while
he's attacking you republicans
your eye's not on the ball you should be
worried about climate change
yeah i mean this one even more
specifically he's attacking us
he has made those comments in the
context of the police acted stupidly one
of his first controversies as president
and he was talking quite clearly about
all of our friends here uh mr glenn beck
who after that comment was famously on
fox and friends and
called the president a racist and
there's things i love about
glenn uh and one of them is uh he will
just
kind of come out with it even when he's
not a hundred percent locked in on
exactly what he means
you know he knows he's got a he's got a
great instinct
that something's going on and it
sometimes takes him a while to work
through it
one of the reasons he's been so
successful he's in the radio hall of
fame is because he works through that
with the audience often
and what he was feeling out at that
moment was
critical race theory it was this exact
thing i mean he was criticized for
saying
oh well it seems like obama has a
problem with the white culture
go back to obama's book that's those are
the exact
words he uses the white culture and now
the white culture
whiteness is evil whiteness is terrible
it's so
commonplace in our everyday discussions
it
it doesn't even stand out i mean he
really was on on the mark on something
there and
and he you know has gone through a long
struggle with that comment but i think
in in general sense it's been vindicated
pretty strongly i mean what is
critical race theory except racism right
and the irony of course is that there
are really no white people i mean i
suppose a tiny sliver of sort of
irrelevant people but
no mainstream white people are running
around saying white is better it's the
critical race theory people that in
essence are saying white is better
because it means you're on time and you
work hard and you know that two plus two
equals four
and in effect you don't judge people by
the color of their skin david do you
think
we have the right tools let's say this
this new sort of right alliance has the
right tools
to fight critical race theory
effectively i mean it seems like we've
just seen everything crumble
under the weight of this well it is
crumbling under the weight of this and
it's just getting started it's not going
to go anywhere anytime soon and the
power that we have
is at the local level the thing that is
uh is very
alarming and should be alarming to every
single viewer watcher
is that there are individuals in the
school boards that are approving
uh this this doctrine that is literally
teaching
racism uh and and in order for us to
literally take back the power we've got
to not only be informed our the parents
in every school district around this
country need to be informed as to who is
making the decisions
on who is on what curriculums are going
to let into their schools
and then they've got to make changes
there's already you know it's it led up
to this i think crt was first originated
in 89 it's been growing for you know a
couple decades and it's reached this
point where now it's kind of
introduct introducing into the
mainstream curriculums of our schools
and being widely accepted and being
approved it sounds like by obama by
dismissing it
the parents of these kids need to get in
their school board meetings find out
what's going on
replace the individuals that are okay
with this kind of doctrine that's the
real power that we've got as parents
uh waking up getting involved and taking
action now well said i
i do want to note also by the way in
case mara gay the new york times op-ed
lady is watching this show that i'm
pretty sure the flag behind
harris is not meant to be a white
supremacist flag i know
she saw some flags on the left she saw
some flags on the
long island expressway it freaked her
out